les lapins se font capturer pas un
méchant suprême fasciste qui les a
alignés les uns derrière les autres
il coiffe les lapins avec des chapeaux
blancs noirs chaque lapin ne voit que
les chapeaux des lapins qui sont devant
lui
chacun près l'autre en partant de
l'arrière chaque lapin doit deviner la
couleur de son propre chapeau
collectivement les lapins n'ont le droit
qu'à une erreur si de lapin ou plus se
trompent
alors le suprême fasciste et les tuera
tous les lapins sont super intelligents
et ils ont trente secondes pour
concevoir une stratégie
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'ils
devraient faire n'hésitez pas à mettre
pause pour y réfléchir
alors vous voulez la réponse eh bien non
je la donnerai pas aujourd'hui je vous
invite à y réfléchir ensemble dans les
commentaires
mais si vous connaissez déjà la réponse
ne se posait pas les autres essayez
plutôt de les guider de donner quelques
pistes de réflexion et on reviendra sur
tout ça dans les commentaires du
prochain épisode donc ce qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ce problème
mais une variante de ce problème
énervé par les lapins curan sur résoudre
une énigme le suprême fasciste capture a
maintenant une infinité d'entre eux
comme précédemment il les aligne à
l'infini et leur donna des chapeaux
blancs et noirs
cette fois c'est dans le cas où un
nombre infini de lapin se trompe que
suprême fasciste sévira et cette fois
non seulement il tuera tous les lapins
mais il ira même jusqu à réécrire tous
les livres de maths avec les chiffres
romains ou la mère n'est pas légal mais
que peuvent bien faire nos lapins dans
ce cas là pour résoudre ce problème
impossible du suprême fasciste et bien
si vous connaissez l'action du choix je
vous inviter à réfléchir
dans le cas contraire et bien on va voir
la réponse ensemble et vous allez voir
que le plus fou c'est qu'avec l'axiom du
choix les lapins vont réussir à résoudre
ce problème sans qu'aucun lapin en est à
écouter ses prédécesseurs pour résoudre
ce problème
nos lapins commence par considérer
toutes les manières selon lesquelles le
suprême fasciste aura pu choisir les
chapeaux les lapins place ensuite toutes
les suites possibles de chapeau sur une
espèce de carte du monde des suites de
chapeau sauf que certaines suites de
chapeaux sont équivalentes
en fait on va dire que deux suites de
si elles ne diffèrent que d'un nombre
infini de chapeau comme ses deux suites
dans cet exemple là et du coup on peut
imaginer que chaque suite va être
équivalente à un très grand nombre de
suivre peu de chapeau mieux encore si je
considère l'ensemble de toutes les
suites de couleurs de chapeau et bien je
peux partitionner cet ensemble je peux
le découper en région de sorte que deux
suites seront équivalentes si et
seulement si elles sont dans la même
région
est-ce que les lapins mon mât d'enfer
c'est élire pour chaque région une
capitale c'est à dire une suite qui va
être la suite qui représente toutes les
autres suites équivalente de la région
et devinez quoi
le tour est joué ça y est on a notre
stratégie ce que les lapins vont faire
c'est que oui il voit devant eux une
infinité de couleurs de chapeau et en
particulier il y as derrière chaque
lapin un nombre fini de chapeau
du coup chaque lapin connaît exactement
la suite des couleurs de chapeau choisi
par le suprême fasciste à un nombre fini
d'erreur près autrement dit il c'est
exactement dans quelle région de
l'ensemble de toutes les suites de
chapeau se trouve le choix du suprême
fasciste et bien chaque lapin va tout
simplement considérer la capitale de
cette région est dire la couleur du
chapeau qui lui est donné selon cette
capitale de sorte que les lapins
ensemble en tant que collectif vont dire
exactement la suite des couleurs du
chapeau de la capitale en gros ils vont
jouer la capitale de la région dans
laquelle ils savent qu'ils se trouvent
les lapins ont donc deviner la capitale
de la région dans laquelle se trouve la
suite une du suprême fasciste du coup on
sait pas reconstruction des régions qui
elle ne diverge ras de la suite du
suprême fasciste cette capitale que d'un
nombre fini d'erreurs et donc le nombre
d'erreurs que font les lapins est un
nombre fini les lapins donc résolu le
problème et ça c'est un peu et rouge est
bien pour certains mathématicien le fait
qu'on ait résolu ce problème qui est
impossible d'apparence en tout cas
montre qu il y a eu une faille quelque
part dans ton raisonnement et en
particulier pour beaucoup de
mathématiciens la faille du réseau non
que je viens de vous donner le fait
qu'on a réussi à élire une capitale pour
chacune des régions de l'ensemble des
suites ou autrement dit la faille réside
dans notre utilisation de l'action du
choix l'action du choix c'est celui qui
dit que si on a une infinité de régions
non vide alors il est possible d'élire
une capitale pour chacune des régions
ça peut paraître évident et pourtant
pour la plupart des mathématiques déjà
on peut s'en passer
mais surtout il semble impossible de d
hier cet axiome les actions plus
fondamentaux de la logique ou de la
théorie des ensembles et pendant des
décennies le statut de l'axone du choix
semblait être dans un état quantique
superposer à la fois vrai et faux
en 1924 alfred tard ce qui prouva que
l'action du choix était équivalent au
fait que toutes ensemble à à la même
taille que l'ensemble accroît à
autrement dit l'axiome du choix est vrai
si et seulement si il existe toujours
une direction entre a et accroît à les
détails importe peu et je vous renvoie
vers les vidéos des ligier et de
sciences étonnant pour en savoir plus
ce qui est vraiment amusant c'est que
tarski soumis un article avec la preuve
de cette équivalence aux comptes rendus
de l'académie des sciences à paris
fréchette le bègue était responsable de
la re lecture de cet article
fraîcheur répondit que l'équivalence
entre deux propositions clairement vrai
n'était pas à zulte à nouveau et le
bègue écrivait qu une équivalence entre
deux théorème peau n'avait aucun intérêt
l'article de karski furent jetés et
tarski ceux promis de ne plus jamais
rien soumettre à l'académie des sciences
de paris dont les convictions en interne
sembler contradictoire sans que personne
ne soit au courant
la même année parce qu'il voulait
comprendre les conséquences de cet
intrigant accepte du choix fait une
autre découverte encore plus surprenante
avec stéphane banach qui découvrit
khaled de l'action du choix vous pouvez
couper une orange en cinq morceaux puis
recoller les morceaux pour former deux
orange identiques à l'orangé initiales
liées a fait une excellente vidéo sur ce
paradoxe apparent que l'on appelle le
paradoxe l'open art ascii
plus étrange encore avec l'action du
choix on peut aussi ordonner les
nombreuses réel à l'aide des ordis notre
ans pilier de l'épisode 8 alors que l'on
sait aussi qu'on ne peut pas déterminer
de façon explicite d'y arriver
pire encore en
963 paul cohen a même prouvé que même
avec l'action du choix on ne peut pas
savoir si les ordinaux jusqu'à oméga un
suffiront à lister les réelles avec des
ordis outrance fini ou s'il faudra
utiliser des ordis nos encore plus grand
ce résultat stupéfiant de paul cohen qui
prouve l'impossibilité de prouver quoi
que ce soit sur les ordis de nécessaire
à lister les réels et ceux que l'on
appelle d'indécis d'imputer 8 côte est
du continent
plus généralement le théorème 2rbds
elodie qu'il est toujours possible
d'ordonner les éléments d'un ensemble à
l'aide des ordis notre ans finit en fait
ce théorème dit même que la possibilité
de toujours trouver un bon ordre à tout
ensemble est équivalent à l'axiome du
choix dans un autre genre il ya le lem
de zorn qui dit que tout ensemble
inductif admet un élément maximale bon
les détails sont un petit peu technique
et je veux pas rentrer dans ces détails
dans cette vidéo ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que seul m 2 horn et à l'instar du
tome 2 est un mélo équivalent on lui
aussi à l'axiome du choix et si je vous
raconte tout ceci c'est pour vous sortir
l'intrigante citation de jerry bona qui
affirmait la boutade suivante
l'axiome du show a clairement vrai le
théorème 2 rbds et l'eau clairement faux
et le lem de zorn qui sait d'où tu
collectionnes le choix est très très
bizarre et qui a des conséquences très
très insatisfaisante
cependant la cuve du choix est aussi
parfois bien utile
l'action du choix permet ainsi de
prouver que la notion de taille des
seins finit bien ce que l'on pourrait
croire que tout espace vectoriel admet
une base vectorielle que tout à nos
unités arnon trivial admet un idéal
maximale que tout corps admet une
extension algébrique non closes que tout
grave connexes admet un arbre couvrant
ou encore que toute logique du premier
ordre cohérente admet un modèle saas est
ce que l'on appelle le théorème de
complétude de gödel dont j'ai déjà parlé
dans les commentaires de l'épisode
précédent
bref l'action du choix et 6
utile ici pratique que la plupart des
mathématiciens le considèrent
aujourd'hui vrai même si certains se
plaisent à rétorquer qu'il implique
quand même des trucs aussi étrange aussi
bizarre aussi faux que le fait de
pouvoir résoudre le problème du supprime
fasciste
enfin à parler du théorème de gucci
d'années jean baptiste on doit on se
pose la question de la croissance de la
suite de goodstein vient ça dépend de la
graine
lorsqu'on part d'une bonne can 4 on peut
voir qu'au début ce cas de suite la
croissance est à peu près linéaire mais
si on passe à d'autres graines fois
mclaren dix neuf où la graine un google
la décroissance qui sont super super
exponentielle fondé croissant de malades
mais bien sûr tout ça ne grossit pas du
tout aussi vite que la fonction de good
time qui mesure la longueur des suites
de gucci times on avait vu par exemple
que pour 3 la longueur de la suite de
good time était 3 4 3 2 1 0 mais ça
faisait 6 et dès qu'on passait à une
grève de quatre la longueur de la suite
de guyane étaient trois fois de
puissance
quelques centaines de millions passer un
nombre qui est beaucoup plus grand et
puis on avait vu aussi que la fonction
de gauche line pour la valeur 12 étaient
déjà plus grand que le nombre de grammes
comme ça ça croit avoir un très très
très très très vite
en fait en un certain sens la croissance
outre à rappeler de la fonction de
greenstein et si rapide qu'elle échappe
à l'arithmétique de kernault arthur
belleville nous demande aussi ça a
quelque chose à voir avec le hydre de
kirby paris c'est ce super épisode de
ligier en fait oui c'est même très très
très très lié en fait l'article de kirby
paris de 1982 montre à la fois que le
goûteur de woodson échapper
l'arithmétique de p and o et que le
leader de kirby parisse aussi je me
permets d'insister sur le fait que si
vous n'avez pas bien compris l'épisode
précédent d'aller voir la vidéo d'al
jissah complément excellent cyril
pouvoir nous demande si au lieu
d'utiliser le oméga ou n'aura pas pu
utiliser juste un nombre super méga
géant en fait c'est vraiment pas évident
déjà de trouver ce nombre on a vu que si
on prend une suite de graines 3 dont on
pouvait prendre aux médias qui était
égal à 10 pour prouver que la suite de
gauche a le gr3 finissait pour le cas de
la graine 4d là c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué puisqu'il faut prendre aux
médias plus grand que trois offres de
puissance
antenne 2 millions et puis dès qu'on
passe à la graine 5
on est complètement perdue on sait plus
trop quel nombre construire alors on
aurait peut-être envie de construire une
suite du coup de nombreux qui à la base
d'oméga sonné nombre de plus en plus
grands et qui grandissent avec la graine
mais ça ça reviendrait à définir la
fonction de gunstett qui échappe à
l'arithmétique de piano que ne peut pas
construire dans l'arithmétique de piano
et du coup c'est pour ça que tous ces
arguments ne tiennent pas dans la police
inoccupé à nous on ne peut pas choisir
un nombre suffisamment grand pour toutes
les crèmes ou on peut même pas faire
croire
c'est ce nombre suffisamment rapidement
pour gérer toutes les graines ça c'est
une explication partielle au fait qu'il
nous faut vraiment utiliser ce oméga
pour pouvoir prouver le terrain de
goldstein et ça ça pose la question que
pose le team et ben pourquoi est-ce que
ce oméga pourquoi est ce que ces ordis
notre ans finit ne sont pas dans
l'arithmétique de piano est bien le
problème des nombreux transferts
notamment due aux médias c'est qu'il ne
satisfait pas l'action de de
l'arithmétique de p and o l'axiome de
l'arithmétique de piano nous disait que
si on prend en est un objet non nul de
l'arithmétique de p and o alors ils
devaient avoir un prédécesseur
ou plus précisément il existait un autre
objet d'art avec musique de piano dont
il était le successeur
et ça c'est pas vrai pour oméga oméga
n'a pas deux prédécesseurs il n'ya pas
d'ordinaire qui vient juste avant oméga
et du coup les axiomes de exclut les
ordis notre ans finit de l'arithmétique
de piano et c'est pas une mauvaise chose
c'est une bonne chose puisque la est
message de paix à nos cherche à décrire
les anti naturel pas des objets comme
les nombres trans fini et enfin j arrive
et nous demandent si vous pourrez pas
utiliser des idées si
hier la preuve du temps pour prouver la
conjecture de syracuse donc la confiture
ou syracuse si l'on connaissait pas ça
du super vidéo de micmacs explique en
très rapidement en fait c'est une espèce
de machine aussi qui bat à chaque fois
prendre un nombre
et si ce nombre est père il va lui
divisé par deux si les impairs et ben il
va lui multiplié par trois et y ajouter
et puis il va rien leur jt le résultat
et ainsi de suite et aconit hureaux
syracuse et andy que peu importe le
nombre que l'on donne à cette machine
est bien si on fait tourner la manivelle
encore et encore on finira par tomber
sur la valeur 1 et en fait on finira par
bouclé par la suite un cas de 1,5 à 2,5
à 2 5 à 2 heures c'est la suite alors
cette conjecture est ouverte un sein
pour les mots vers personne ne connaît
la réponse à cette question est celui
qui trouvera la réponse à cette question
si surtout si elle une preuve
oui en effet c'est le cas et bien sûr la
soupe quelqu'un de très très connus
comme en faut faire pour y arriver
pour prouver la peinture de syracuse est
ce qu'on peut utiliser les idées
similaires à hauteur de gauche taiwo
chance à rien si je le savais je serais
déjà un mathématicien luttera connu
cependant inverse on peut utiliser
l'exemple du littoral de guichen pour
suggérer une issue possible peu
satisfaisante aux yeux de beaucoup de ce
prêtre de syracuse
à savoir on a prouvé dans le cas du
théorème de gottesheim que l'on ne
pouvait pas le prouver
si on était dans l'arithmétique de piano
peut-être que la conjecture de syracuse
n'a pas de preuve dans l'arithmétique de
piano peut-être même pire encore sa
sovan a pas de preuve
même dans la théorie des ensembles même
si on inclut l'accès aux hommes du choix
ou l'hypothèse d'une notice à soi même
avec des hypothèses encore plus
farfelues comme
les infinis inaccessible ce ne sera
peut-être pas possible de prouver même
avec eux ces outils la conjecture de
syracuse est possible simplement qu'il
n'y a pas de preuve à cela et du coup
peut-être que ne saura jamais si on
finit toujours par tomber sur un
peut-être que c'est vrai qu'on ne
pourrait jamais sur un an mais qu'il
n'est pas possible de démontrer javan on
n'en sait rien elle espère que vous avez
mais c'est elisa d'après toi on va
parler de la diagonale dévastatrice de
kantor on verra notamment qu'il existe
une infinité d'infini si vous avez aimé
cet épisode conseil le lac est le
commentaire de partager n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner pour ne pas rater les
futurs épisodes merci aux tee-shirts
polos et j'espère que je verrai la
prochaine fois il est tout à fait
raisonnable pour un mathématicien de
découper pour deux invités un gâteau
sphérique en cinq parts de façon à ce
que chacun des invités reçoivent la
totalité du gâteau morozov mathematics
and which you can do bad all we dance we
had a good day date du nouveau statut
est une machine très lente ruelle